hi dad hi Gracie thank you so much for
coming today thanks for having me we're
looking forward to the conversation
happy new beers really nice thank you
all for being here I appreciate I was
hoping we could start when you were in
our shoes when you were just starting
out on your career your first job out of
Business School was as an analyst at
American Airlines you moved around
between a couple of different airline
companies after that but never left the
industry what drew you to that first job
at American and to the airline industry
um yeah you're you're gonna test my
memory it's a long time ago
but no I am a lot of people are industry
you will that I you will find it you
know just grew up you know with jet fuel
in their veins and sit and watch
airplanes take off you know when they
were 12 years old at the airport I
didn't do any of that stuff
I was not a huge commercial aviation
enthusiast or anything like it I I was I
was looking for a job I'd gone straight
through from undergrad to graduate
school my concentration was in finance I
wanted to go somewhere where finance was
important so I looked toward Tarte I
looked toward Catholic heavily
capitalized industries and Airlines
popped up so as a number of others so it
wasn't so much the airlines and I was
fortunate enough that the time of
American Airlines was building a trying
to build a hub in Nashville Tennessee
where I was where I was getting my MBA
so they came to campus I interviewed and
they invited me back to Dallas I like
the people there really was as simple as
that it was I knew I wanted to go
somewhere where what I was or what I was
reasonably proficient at mattered yeah
so that was as targeted as I did though
is it was then it was just but having
done it it's I loved it it's a fantastic
business it's really dynamic so that's
kind of why I stayed and I think but it
was it wasn't anything more scientific
that makes sense and and but you
did stay in the industry and many of us
many of our generation our job offers a
lot of us our next jobs we won't be
there for more than a couple of years
what's your advice is someone who stayed
in the same industry for so long to
people who are thinking about jumping
between companies and industries over
the course of their careers oh yeah
again I mean sit I did oh I know is what
what I did so it's hard to suggest that
that's the only way to do it is not but
you know what happened with me again is
I got into this business I found I
really enjoyed it
what I what I liked about the airline
and is about the airline business is
that all the disciplines are really
important I said I want to go somewhere
finance matter but fineness doesn't
matter but so does you know it's a it's
a consumer product so marketing is
incredibly important it's there's no
more complex operation in the world so
logistics is incredibly important and
valued the maintenance function is
really a manufacturing function so every
discipline is really important and how
you make all those things come together
is really important so what you know
what I liked about it is the ability to
gravitate to different items areas over
time you know so but so much staying in
the industry I don't know I know at
times they were you know I contemplated
doing other things it wasn't that I that
I think I need to stay in this business
for any pretty reason just the
opportunities that came around we're in
toward continuing to be in the same
business now I don't think I can do
anything else is all I've done but you
know so I don't know I will say that
it's certainly nice when we bring in
people from the outside because you can
bring in a fresh perspective and people
in our business tendency you know have
hold on to some views of the past that
maybe we don't want to hold on to
anymore so there's always some value it
brings people in from the outside but
there's also a tremendous amount of
value of having people who have been in
the
and know it and have seen the cycles and
understand so I think either way we need
some of each and but there certainly is
if we if we find someone who's just
moving arrest in for a couple years and
that it's not particularly helpful
that's because it's just it takes longer
than that to really figure out what's
going on when you when you first arrived
at this company that has so many
different disciplines that are important
you hadn't been watching the plane's
take off when you were a kid and there's
a lot of value from the industry
expertise just starting out how did you
make a name for yourself in a company
like that um yeah you show up and do
your job and you know try and make sure
that you're being responsive to what
people are to what the organization is
looking for I wasn't again I don't think
I was yeah I wasn't this incredibly hard
driving cutthroat I'm going to make sure
that I get this job for someone else
does but I certainly cared about what I
did I took it seriously and I worked
really hard I took pride in the work
that I did and people noticed that and
so it wasn't so much you know that I was
going to figure out how I got to this
child by this time but rather I showed
up and did the job that I was asked to
do I think I did it pretty well and
people recognize that and they want you
to do more things and and and of course
then you know what really matters is as
you start moving up in an organization
the skills that might have been really
helpful as an analyst are not
particularly the ones that are what the
ones that are as important as a manager
so you got to figure out how to adapt
and do those things but anyway I tried
to do what I was asked to do and it I
took it really seriously I worked I
worked pretty hard because I because it
mattered to me so and but if you do that
people people will find you yeah were
there any key people or key events that
that helped doing especially when you
were moving up into new positions where
maybe you didn't have the skills yet
yeah well you know what I remember
back then where my career really started
to progress faster is when I was
promoted I was I was a pretty good
analyst but there were definitely better
analyst than me smarter this is like
good at Lotus 1-2-3 or whatever the hell
we use back then so yeah so anyway they
can think of build a spreadsheet faster
and they did so I was I was pretty good
but definitely the best where my career
started progressing is when I was
promoted to you know managing a small
group of people and I've always liked
working the teams played team sports
growing up that's what I you know I that
was I was comfortable in that
environment and I quickly realized that
you know I can if I can just get these
five people who are smarter than me to
work together we can do a lot more than
the six of us can independently and
that's and I was and I did find that I
anyway I think I did that role better
than certainly my peers at the time I
was able to produce more I tried to make
sure they all got credits and then
people wanted to be on my team and as a
result that's when things
you know started taking off from me a
little more christine a lot of these
dynamics are the dynamics of a more
traditional complex company that's been
around for a while and has its
hierarchies a lot of us are looking at
jobs in Silicon Valley where we move
fast and break things which isn't
necessarily how I would describe
American Airlines so give us the other
perspective what can we learn at this
point in our careers from an established
company that we couldn't learn at a
startup um yeah um oh that's a that's a
hard question for me to answer you again
back back when I came out you know there
wasn't an internet and there weren't
people you know the best in Bryce didn't
go work at startups they went and worked
at established firms so it's what I knew
but look the basic principles I'm
certain are the same that is you know
leadership skills getting people to work
as a unit communicating with people in a
way that they understand what the
the organization is in a way that they
feel motivated to produce so that's
that's how you that's how you're
successful a large organization I can't
imagine how you're not how you're
successful in a smaller organization and
look this this large organization stuff
well it may sound old and stodgy you
know we I think the reason our team has
done as well as we have you know given
the cards we were handed anyway is
because I think we think much more like
a startup that startup mentality you
know we took risk others wouldn't take
we did things people thought were crazy
and there's so much value to be created
if you're willing to do that in large
organizations because the organization
doesn't it will reward behavior but but
it doesn't encourage the behavior you
know if any way any of any of you if
asked you know look this is a I'll give
you a roll of dice you know if it comes
up six I'll give you a $50 but it comes
up it didn't come to six you know you
got to pay me five wrong I say oh of
course you know it's it can be ten to
one odds and some of that's one and six
if you try and do that and if you
mention that to your boss and a large
organization I got this idea he's gonna
the boss will say weights like you tell
me five out of six times I'm gonna it's
not going to work I'm gonna look bad
five out of six times what doing that so
but those of us who are willing to say
what he thought I don't care it's a
great bet we're going to do and do that
do extremely well because the
risk-reward relationship works of course
like it does everywhere else and you're
an environment where risk is less
encouraged so those so the reward is is
much higher than it would be if everyone
was actually taking the same level of
risk or had the same attitude so look I
you know again I only know what I only
know what I've been through but you know
I don't feel like it's been you know
boring and stodgy it's been incredibly
dynamic and exciting and the fun part is
is taking these risk and seeing and when
others don't and you know having some
things that others would look at and
think oh god that didn't work for you
which we say what
we it's exactly without screaming we I
would never I would do the exact same
thing because it was the right decision
just because it didn't just because it
came up - doesn't mean it was the wrong
decision to take that bad
it was the PERT was a right decision so
and as long as you keep doing those
things particularly in an organization
where you're not competing with a lot of
people who are doing the same thing you
can do really well and is this
perspective you've developed about you
know being willing to take the risk has
this developed and changed over your
career I don't think so
I got I'm you know I don't know I used
to like going to Vegas a lot when I was
younger um so and you know look I've I'm
a big proponent of risk-taking always
have been so and like I say it's helped
me a lot and you know things like you
know just in the in the introduction you
know my career when I left you is this
is inside airline stuff so sorry but you
know back when I left American Airlines
and whatever that was 1991 now all
everyone American Airlines
that was that was the place to be if
you're you know that we hired 40 MBAs a
year we were the best of the brightest
and no one went to work for Northwest
Airlines for God's sakes from American
but I did because because because I
could do a lot more at Northwest and I
could an American so you know that's why
I'm in anyway this that's I would
encourage people you know to go take
risk and it's it that's what I've been
doing for a long time
good since the Vegas days exactly it'd
be combined with your risk-taking style
there's also a lot out there who say you
have a leadership style that's very
humble very confident but very humble
and the airline industry has a lot of
folks with some pretty big egos good
competence yes yes everyone's got the
confidence but the humility I think is a
distinctive feature is this or what are
the trade-offs between the two different
styles when you're running such a
complex organization so many different
people to communicate with as you
express before okay well thanks for the
characterization I appreciate that I
hope it's true
what what I know is that this is this is
a huge team sport and there's no
individual it makes a difference and the
way it makes a difference is if you get
the whole team pulling together and
working together so I'm stunned
sometimes to see how some individuals
try and you know position themselves
because I can't imagine what it's like
to work for that person when you're the
one doing all the work and they're
taking all the credit yeah so I try not
to do that and it's hard by the way
because people want to do that that you
know media only wants to talk to me and
so and and they and they didn't everyone
wants to try and simplify it into you
made this decision you and this is human
I didn't make those decisions that
somebody else made this decision I was
just I said okay
so at any rate it's it's not it's not I
don't think it's a conscious attempt to
try and be different than anybody's just
who we are and what we've learned long
ago is you know if we all work as a team
and stick together as a team we can do
really good things but if we all if any
one of us tries to make it about us then
it starts to fall apart so that's worked
for us I don't other ways work for other
people that's just what works for us
yeah building on that the airline
industry is one that invokes a lot of
negative sentiment among customers
sometimes I know the Wall Street Journal
I've heard it mentioned The Wall Street
Journal recently published a report
showing that American Airlines was
ranked last in sort of overall ranking
of US airlines for for 2015 I didn't
read that one I'll send it to you sure
it's wrong probably probably just a
slip-up maybe I was looking at it upside
down but
well what I want to know is in a team
sport and you're the team captain and
there's results like this how do you
lead the team well you understand the
results and make sure it did look I did
read the article and you didn't read it
upside down the but look those are we're
in the middle of an integration during
the time that was that was measured so
things like what they measured are
important but some of the things I
measure are really hard to do when
you're certain when you run to separate
airlines like baggage connections you
know when we've got people connecting
from US Airways to American Airlines and
you know it's it's harder so that all
that we're well aware of that that's the
problem of integration and we are that
stuff's fixed so we won't be last next
year American Airlines is one airline
now and we'll get the loop so that so
anyway first and foremost that's the
answer but you're - you're brought to
that specific set of circumstances but
I'm not about to suggest that where do
we do everything great it's a great
business and people shouldn't complain
it's a it's a difficult it's a difficult
function to transport people you know
through bad weather like we're about to
Halen in the East Coast and people pay a
lot for the for the product and there's
an it look if we do everything perfectly
if we do our jobs perfectly well that
they're pressed perfectly maintained
everyone shows up on time everyone does
their job exactly as they should the
best we're going to do in terms of
on-time performance over the course of a
year anyway it's probably around 85% 85%
of the time we can guarantee you should
expect at the in the very very best run
airline that you're going to arrive
within 40 by the way the definition
Valentine's within 14 minutes of your
scheduled arrival time which is nice too
that's our government but nonetheless so
that's that's so you know what other
business you know has 15% failure rates
that you know and for a product but
that's entirely to the weather that's
you know in the example ice cave there's
no maintenance cancellations that we 50
percent of our flights get delayed
because of what
so we have we have this challenge of a
product that you know is a means to an
end
most people don't buy airline tickets to
fly around on an airplane they're trying
to get somewhere else and is also
because because of how complicated it is
and how capital-intensive is it's
reasonably expensive so they expect it
to work as a means to an end and when it
doesn't think it's that our challenge is
to make sure that we manage that as well
you know and we're getting much better
at this when things do go wrong make
sure that we were able to respond much
more quickly and get people where they
need to go and because people do
understand weather but they still want
to get where they're trying to go so
anyway I've already forgot what the
question was Gracie but we work really
hard at doing in a difficult in a
difficult job to do it really well and
to focus on customers we have a
phenomenal team of people we get over a
hundred thousand poised who who are just
out there doing a great job every day
it's a really noble thing they do they
get beat up sometimes because they're
the ones standing there when they
completed the plane can't go but the
reality is you know those people are we
make copy they make commerce run you
know business couldn't operate without
the airline industry they get people to
go see other people they get people to
go see the world and it all happens
because of the work they do and we're
really proud of it but we know we have
to get better at at accommodating
recombination people when things go
wrong and related to things beyond your
control ten days after you became CEO of
US Airways you woke up to the news that
two planes had crashed into the World
Trade Center what went through your head
at that moment and what did you do that
morning yeah I was where I was in
Phoenix at I'm working for America West
Airlines and yeah I was a CEO for ten
days it's a nice ten days and then I'll
rally together so look the immediate
concern of course was for the safety of
our of our of our team so you know
quickly after learning about the flights
of the World Trade Center my phone rang
and it was the oh the FAA was grounding
the entire commercial airline fleet and
so we were putting airplanes down
so the best message I got was you know
hearing that every one of our airplanes
was safe and they were on the ground so
but anyway then it quickly turns into
you know the next three days of trying
to shut down the airspace and those
things but not much longer once once you
get past the immediate safety concerns
and by the way extreme empathy for those
who didn't have their employees safe in
American United but you shortly
thereafter we moved into what are we
going to do about the long-term
viability this business and this in
particular the company that I was
running which the America West Airlines
we we we had arranged a financing with
some suppliers of ours Airbus and GE to
help get us through what was already a
tough time it was arranged but we've not
not fully executed so that of course
fell through we found ourselves in a
position where we absolutely in that
environment did not have have enough
cash to make it through the winter we
were going to go and in that environment
there was no way even in a through it
through a bankruptcy filing to expect
things that would like dip loans that
will allow you to survive we were we
were going to shut the company down
we're going we were going to liquidate
without some sort of capital infusion so
and the only possible way to get a
capital infusion in that environment was
the US government they establish this
government loan guarantee program so I
went from when I took the job in
September of 2001 the one thing I
remember telling the board is look I
know I can do all this stuff you know
I've done done operations I've done I've
done the marketing so I've done the
finance side the only thing I really
haven't done is government affairs but
that's okay because we're this little
airline in Phoenix we never had do
anything with Washington really it's
more the bigger airlines mess with that
well I was I was found myself living in
Washington DC you know lobbying for for
a government loan for the next three
months crash course yeah
and how did you communicate so you had a
lot of communications with with the
government the months that followed how
did you think about the various
communications to the public to
customers employees shareholders yeah
well we tried to make him think
everything was okay
and even though we weren't quite sure it
was your honest but let every by now
that we were going to get this done even
though we weren't certain we were so the
communication was was uh anyway it was
it was communication was important but
the real important part was trying to
get through this get through the loan
process is by the way this is I'm gonna
embarrass somebody is Marlena slow akin
here hi her father John slug was our
investment banker through all this he he
he lived through this with me um so
anyway you nice to see you Thanks
tell your dad hi um anyway he and I went
through a lot together but so look you
didn't have to give you one quick story
I think can help pull us together and
also this career stuff because seeing
Marlena remind me this look we went
through this process and almost and we
were told by the government no we were
told this you know Marly his father and
I sat there and got you know at the
Department of Transportation dust the
facts you know at cities government
affairs office Friday at 5:00 p.m. so
that he then leave that said you know
we've reviewed your phone and then and
need to tell you that your we cannot
approve your application at this time
which is yes no so and it is worst day
of my life we were going to liquidate
and I didn't know what we're gonna do
about it
I just and again from this time now so
it's now I'm the CEO so I want him in
CEO this is now this is now November
October November so I've been seeing
over two months yeah exactly
so I'm thinking so I just can't help but
think this this didn't turn out right um
my career you know and that's short
gonna be the worst CEO of all time I
will see you over two months we
liquidate the company I'm what am I
going to do and all this kind of mimimi
stuff so which again I don't feel badly
about that that's natural you know get
into jobs you kind of worry about your
career and I was still worried about my
career and what
going to do and here I knew I was going
to be at Isaac this company was known
that was going to liquidate so and
here's this here's the career story so I
go and on that flight home from DC to
Phoenix I'm sorry you have DC to Phoenix
I always get up and talk to our team in
career because it's important and I'll
and I alert from them but I didn't want
to go talk to the flight and it come on
a flight because I knew everyone is this
you know front page news no one knew yet
about this letter but everyone was
asking so I knew they're going to ask
and I knew I couldn't lie to her to the
flight attendants but I also didn't so I
was contemplated just spinning this for
hours in my seat but then I son I can't
do that I got to get up so I go back and
talk and I'm glad I did this flight from
the back asking what's going on I tell
her well gee doesn't be too good right
now um you know I just were fighting
through it but I just I don't feel good
about it and she says what's that going
to mean so look at week eight is done
you know well file bankruptcy will try
and hang on but I'm feel good about that
either and she just looks at me and says
you can't do that I'm I've been doing
this job for ten years I'm a single mom
I've got my life arranged around this
flight attendant job I can't do anything
else I'm really good at it which by the
way she was cuz I'd seen her and you
just can't let that happen
and I'm like yeah so okay but no it was
really helpful so I went back sat my
seat pulled out the damn letter again
and recognized and realized that it said
at this time can't approve it at this
time so okay we you know I landed that
night we went straight to work we worked
our weekend we showed back up in DC
Monday morning Oh John with us with a
new application and these guys that
treasure so what are you doing here I
said you said not this time here's
another application we're not going away
and we kept fighting and we didn't give
up and I mean it's insulting me from
that time you know that that airline
that little America was certainly had to
have that loan that little airline
America West Airlines lived off of wage
advantages other airlines went through
bankruptcy and get their wages down to
ours so all of a sudden we had a new
problem which was we didn't have the
revenue generating capability they did
but
they had the same cost structure of this
now that I am I going to work so we had
to do a merger so we merged the US
Airways and then the US Airways ended up
essentially the same kind of problems so
we didn't murder with American all those
things
none of those was from the time of that
encounter that was i spending time
thinking what's best for my career
everyone I'm was I I'm responsible for
these hard-working people who if we
don't do our jobs right aren't going to
have a job and it's not their fault
they're she's people are fantastic
they're depending upon us to make sure
that we put the company into a position
where they don't worry about whether the
company's going to be there for him so
the reason we worked so hard for those
mergers and the reason I personally work
so hard on it was not because we wanted
to get ourselves in a position of being
CEO of largest airline in the world is
because that was the only way to get
that group people to say forever anyway
the moral this story is for the time I
stopped thinking about my career about
my career and started thinking about
doing my job for a bigger cause my
career took off and so anyway I like
that part but so my message of this is
if you it's hard to do you know you
always hear people say I'll go do what
you love to which I know that's BS I
love playing basketball but I
nobody's gonna pay me to do that so but
but I think that but what really is true
if you can figure out a way to make what
you do be bigger than just you that
that'll work out really well for you and
again it's not that easy so it's a lot
like saying do what you love but if you
can find a way once you find that don't
let go of it because that is that's how
that's when things really start
happening when you when you when you're
not just because look if it had been me
if I'd have been worried about oh gee I
want to be CEO of American Airlines some
point during this whole fight I want to
set up see obvious errors in that bad
I'm fine you know and I'm gonna be fine
I want to move this is okay but that
never crossed our minds because this was
no no we gotta get this done for all
these people that are counting on us so
I'm glad you bring up the mergers cuz I
wanted to ask before we talk about the
success of the US Airways American
merger about what you learned from the
failed attempts merge with United and
continental yeah they weren't failures
oh good I'm already learning you're
reading it upside down again and look
this is this is this is back to the
wrist thing and of course they this is
perceived as failures but it's exactly
what I'm really glad we did it we were
the first one that Gracie's referring to
was shortly after doing the America West
US Airways merger and we'd head and we
were kind of this may actually shorter
than this point we just one year into it
Delta Airlines was in bankruptcy they
were trying they were about to emerge in
bankruptcy we came up with a great idea
of bringing them out of bankruptcy with
a merger within US Airways which hadn't
really even merged of America West very
well yet but it was a good idea it would
have been a really good airline and the
Delta team didn't like it so it turned
into a hostile doesn't happen very often
hostels of companies in bankruptcy but
we tried it we knew going in it was
high-risk and probably and more likely
than not not to work but you know it was
it was the role in the six on the die
huge upside make it work excuse me
and if it didn't work it didn't work so
and also if it didn't work what we knew
is we were going to they would have to
figure out something else to do and they
did what happened is so long story short
that that group of people when you're in
bankruptcy not bored you have creditors
we have a board but people run the
company of the people that you that you
stiffed so the people they owe money
that aren't getting paid are now and
control the company and those people you
know who we were appealing to by saying
look you'll get much more of your money
back because with us than with them you
know kind of believed us but at the end
said look we're going to we're going to
stick with them but they insisted that
that board be changed that board put
people on that we're Pro consolidation
including Richard Anderson who now runs
the place and shortly after the merger
that northwest wind did Delta Wooden did
merger with Northwest I don't think that
would happen if we had done the hostile
and if Delta had merged with Northwest
United wouldn't that our next one then
our next next aborted attempt that we
failed at was trying to then after that
happen merge us air was united and we
got pretty close there but United
eventually told us no and picked
continental instead so you're not
emergent on them another thing that
wouldn't have happened had we not try to
get the first one done so anyway I was
being flippant with you saying we didn't
fail we from the outside those are
failure yeah and that's what they could
expect my point
I don't feel badly about him at all and
people would write at the time oh gee
you know again pointy it on me Doug
failed at this merger attempt but it was
going it didn't do exactly we wanted
them both to work but it progressed us
to where we could do what we needed to
do and it moved the industry where it
needed to move and there was no one else
out there you know trying to make that
happen I don't know where we'd be if we
hadn't try to do this man
and so with American I think one of the
ring reasons it was so successful was
you built this strong relationship with
the labor unions can you talk about the
rates and and what about you as a leader
made those relationships so successful
well again not on me a really good team
of people who you know who we who cared
about
so much about taking care of our team
that we knew that we could do so much
for them that we also knew it was we
best for the employees of American so we
did the rather non-traditional step of
while Americans in bankruptcy beginning
negotiate we were Americans in vagrancy
were we're at US Airways we started
negotiating with the American Airlines
unions for a contract that we would be
willing to sign if indeed a merger got
done these people didn't work for us
they work for American and we're meeting
with them in Phoenix and signing
contracts with them which look I didn't
do lightly there was I know it offended
my friends an American that we were
meeting with their employees but it was
again we had to get this done for our
team it was right thing to do so
to your point we recognized and we
learned it in the Delta transaction
frankly we did have the creditors on
board in the Delta transaction what we
didn't get was the employees on board
they were very proud of Delta they
wanted to stay with Delta and that hurt
us so we recognized we need to get we
need we needed to get the team on board
so we approached the Americans employees
we told that we laid out for them what
we plan to do we told them why we
thought it was better they agreed and it
would have gotten done without him
so it was it worked out well and and now
that the the merger is successful
there's you're the CEO of the largest
airline in the world 120,000 employees
around the globe you're also the father
of three how does being a CEO compared
to being a father father's a lot harder
great kids I try really hard to to be a
father more than a CEO my job I probably
spend more hours and CEO unfortunately
but frankly I learned so much from being
a father that I can use at work um but
anyway it's raising children is this an
amazing thing that's
everybody does it at some point so it's
not like I'm I'm an expert here but you
just just watching the development and
watching how people interact and
watching your kids interact helps me a
lot to understand and to actually go
manage the company so I've learned a lot
more about I've become a better CEO
because I'm a father I try really hard
to be a good father as well you know I
do things to make sure that I'm home as
much as I can be this is this is a
rarity for me where I'm out of time for
a night and it's not required work but I
wanted to do it well I want to do it for
George but and I appreciate it as well
but the so I try and stay home as much
as I can my job requires me to travel I
refuse to do refuse I almost never do
work dinners in Dallas if I'm going to
if I'm going to be home and I we have
been gonna have a meal with my kids if
somebody wants to meet with me of course
that's important to the company we could
do it at lunch or breakfast or we could
do it my office but there's no reason
for me to be going to a dinner in Dallas
so I have rules like that that I just
make sure that if I stay engaged stay
balanced when you move to Dallas after
the acquisition was that a family
conversation about how you balance where
where the kids have been raised versus
where your doing work oh yes
you're good at this so uh do you want to
hear this story I do okay sorry
oh yeah no it was horrible I said the
worst day of my life was that day that I
got the letter this might have been the
worst day Milo this is this is a really
hard day you know my kids we my eldest
who's 20 was born in Minneapolis I was
at Northwest but we moved he was three
weeks old and the other two were born in
Phoenix and that's where they were
raised and so they didn't you know in
this you know this merger was in the
papers all the time and you know I had
one day my daughter who at the time I
guess was she's 15 now so she was 13
sends me a text that says you know this
is Roswell told me the mergers going
through like mrs. Roswell as a friend of
a friend I does I quote I will know
before mrs. Roswell
and I promise I'll tell you but you know
because the Merc that things would
happen like you know a rumor would you
know that you know we got to deal with
them with the unions and that's the okay
the murders gone through is wages
reported as well as sudden my kids are
just going crazy so anyway they didn't
want to move but so anyway the bad part
was when we founded to do it and I've
been telling them all along
quit listen everybody else out when I
when I tell you it's what happened and
don't worry about until then so they
least had some comfort in that and then
one day I had to come home and grab them
and say had you talked to you I mean and
as soon as my daughter walked and she I
said how do you talk to you and pulled
her and we'd already had the two boys
and my wife there and she walked in
their room and just saw that they were
there and just started sobbing so aren't
you played you mean tell that story
that's all right
so now it was really real it's but look
that stuff you got to do she's fantastic
she's fine now she wouldn't she wouldn't
leave doubt so it's all fine but yeah I
mean that's it was a that was a that was
that was the bad part of doing this we
were and again gets back to look if we
were doing this for ourselves what a
stake where we were we were perfectly
fine and happy but you got to do what's
right for the organization and now that
you're at this point the merger the
final pieces have come together
hopefully friends have been made in
Dallas what's next for American as a
company and what's next for you as CEO
um well look we are we are set an
objective ourselves we becoming the
greatest airline in the world we're not
there yet so we have a lot of work to do
we spent the last two years integrating
which is sounds boring and it is but
it's really hard work and it takes a lot
of time and effort and our team is just
knocked the ball out of the park but now
we've got we've gotten through the vast
majority that we still have some left
and now we really need to go start
producing that we are working as one
airline and we know what we need to do
our objective is to be the best in the
world and you know that that's somewhat
nebulous term but we know we're not it
now so that at least we know we have to
make some progress but what it what it
certainly means is you got to be an
airline that people want to fly you have
to be an airline where people want to
work and you have to be an airline where
people where investors want to put their
money and you know we're doing okay on
each of those but we can do a lot better
on each I'm not the best
any of them and we want to be the best
at all so we're going to make huge
improvements to the product it's already
begun that includes the operational
reliability issues that you mentioned
but it also includes you know entire
modernization of the fleet brand-new
airplanes we now the youngest fleet in
the world or in the United States we
have that includes you know Wi-Fi
through our airplanes including
international y flat seats international
taking our Admirals clubs to look like
you know the kind of clubs you'd see
when you fly internationally not just
when you find the United States so make
it a true global airline with a real
global product so we have a lot of work
to do and we have a lot of work to do
with our team there's a lot of history
in American Airlines of management labor
relations that are just horrible I'm not
trying to say anything bad about prior
management they had really different
situation to go through but the result
was a really really bad history that's
hard for people to let go of and so
we're trying to we're trying to convince
people that that's over and this is new
and we try and figure out ways to do
that everyday just surprise people with
something to say wow that's different
this feels different so we got a lot of
work to do with our team to butt in by
the way it's incredibly important to the
first one that this the airline business
is is so much about the employees that
you interact with and their attitudes so
if we can get our employees to be
excited about being where they are our
customers will be much happier on the
airplane and that will help us drive
more passengers to the airline that will
have this meet our goals of getting
return for our investors so it starts
with the employees a lot of exciting
work ahead thanks excellent
I'd like to open up to the audience now
for questions I think are the first one
is from Twitter thanks both for a
wonderful conversation and so the first
question from Twitter comes from a chap
called Jake who says that the Economist
wrote that airlines are wonderful
generators a profit for everyone except
themselves how do you envisage changing
that especially with headwinds such as
climate change and so forth yeah that's
that that was true from you know the
beginning of time until recently we
wrote look where this airline this
business
is transformed and I believe that as
much as I can believe is much like
impossibly stress no one know about no
one very few others seem to believe it
you know our the market doesn't believe
it as you can see with the way you know
our stock trading versus what we're
looking at in terms of earnings it's
hard for our employees to believe it
it's hard for the management team to
believe it but this it's obviously hard
for the Economist to believe it so but
look this this is a real business now
we're producing real returns and we've
got a business now that it's still a
cyclical business people's people will
you know fly less and bad times and fly
more and good times but we're we're
producing profits now that are in line
with general industry actually a little
ahead of them and you know Peaks you
know double the highest earnings the
industry's ever produced even though
we're not hopefully not at peak margins
right now so I think the industry has
been largely transformed mostly due this
largely due the consolidation that we
discuss so I don't that's that's what we
needed to do the the problem with the
world before where everyone else made
money and we didn't all of our suppliers
made money Boeing made money that's by
the way how America West and others
stayed around because those who lived
off of ours off of our carcass needed us
to be around for a little more so they'd
loan us money to keep us kicking around
you know I on three occasions received
loans from either GE or Airbus to save a
company from going bankruptcy go into
bankruptcy America West and US Airways
so but we don't no one talks about
anywhere I'm kind of doing that we're
out raising you know we raised last week
a billion dollars of aircraft financing
at below 4% so this is anyway the answer
to that question if you'd asked me five
years ago or 10 years ago was we've got
to get consolidation done because the
industry's to fragment and we can't
provide the we can't provide to
consumers what they want which is the
ability to you know have one airline
take them everywhere they want to go and
as a result we all end up trying to do
that and we are incredibly inefficient
so I think
Bastin a lot of questions there's mics
going around morning thanks for coming
sure I really appreciated your remarks
on teamwork it made me think right away
of one of your agents in Raleigh your
name is Tammy fields we fly a ton and
she has basically adopted our family she
keeps an eye on like awards seed
searches that we're trying to do to
Tokyo or somewhere and calls me up when
something comes through just so far
above and beyond the call of duty we
were stranded one time in Peru
it was Tammy that got us out of the fix
and goddess flights and you know pulled
whatever strings needed to be pulled
really the kind of success story you're
looking for I'd like to give you her
name when you're finished if that's okay
i got it and i see my colleague down
there typing into his eyes I thought we
good Tammy fields in Raleigh
we will definitely let her know Tammy
fields in Raleigh thank you for telling
me we have we do we have a phenomenal
group of people like those things tell
me hi um I want to ask about how you
keep loyal customers given the recent
award program devaluations among your
competitors United in Delta and
Americans impending award devaluation of
March 22nd how do you look at customer
loyalty and maintain you know their
trust in their business yeah thanks we
don't view it as devaluation we view as
a change and and it look it is I mean
this is these programs you know when
they were established for whatever
reason they were established as you know
you you earn
we measured loyalty about how many miles
you fly and that's one way to do it but
we don't you know we don't we don't
report our PNL as miles flown minus
expenses its revenues minus expenses and
you know what's more important and what
we want to stim to reward even for most
people miles on revenues or a reasonable
approximation but with that model you
had these very very
odd things we created people don't pay
you know very fine the lowest possible
fare they could find and flying spinning
there weekend's flying around the lowest
fares they could find so they get free
travel somewhere else that's any look we
love those people and not trying those
are customers of ours but but when they
when that happens what we as an airliner
choosing to do is give that individual
the first-class seat to Paris
instead of the individual who who didn't
fly as many miles and actually spend his
time at his weekend's at home but during
the week paid full fare and that doesn't
that's not the right model so it's a
shift in the model it's one of these
things again where it's a transformation
so everyone that grew up and that old
model says that you're making this worse
for me but we're not making it worse for
everyone it's worse for some it's better
for others and I think it's I think it's
more fair and more equitable and it's
rewarding what we want to reward which
is those people who fly us you know the
you know in who pay the most and it will
purchase the fares that you know are you
know not just going around and trying to
find you know hundred-dollar fares trans
Khan's on a weekend to figure out how
you get more miles so again that's it's
great they do that that we we encouraged
that by the model we had that's that we
we need we'd like to actually have those
seats for the people that are there
producing the most revenue for us and
hello it took to be as from Germany I
would like to talk about technology
because I haven't heard this at all
today I mean I remember like 15 years
ago I was reading somewhere internet in
the plains I got very excited I was very
addictive to internet back then and then
it took 15 years until at least in
Europe it was most of the airplanes
available and even now I mean easyJet
right now I mean Lufthansa just started
it took like 15 years until people were
able to use Internet in the u.s. it was
a bit earlier but it was still taking a
long time so my question is like how in
the future you can guarantee the
technologies being integrated much
earlier into airplanes especially in
regard
of customer experience because I mean I
would love to have already in American
Airlines app where I could upgrade
myself during a plane maybe for a
special prize on business class where
maybe could skip the line if it's it or
maybe get fast boarding because there's
no huge queue and I feel like I'm just
tired I mean I really feel like the
customer experience which a lot of
online companies are offering at the
mobile technologies out there has
arrived at the airplane
airlines thank you very much yeah no
look we are we're moving as fast as we
possibly can and because of because of
customer demand because of people like
you who are insisting the reality is
Wi-Fi on aircraft now that you talked
about there what you know I remember us
sitting around and debating it and
Deonte because there's no way it can
possibly pay for itself we got to carry
this stuff around be honest this is
these are antennas that communicate down
to cell towers and they're really
expensive and they're heavy and you know
people get you know there's no where we
kind of people pay for it but the once
it was on the airplane on a few
customers started saying the airplane
doesn't have Wi-Fi anywhere so there's
no choice because you because we need to
have it and it came really really
quickly so I don't think those have so
much technology as maybe resistance from
Airlines to go do something that that we
couldn't cost justify but that's all
behind us now and this this is this is
going so fast we're all trying to figure
out how to leapfrog somebody else as it
relates to you know some of things
you're talking about we we are we're
working diligently to figure out
everything we can to make sure the
customer experience can be done as much
through technology as possible some of
the things you described we simply can't
do because you know because the
regulations we have to live with you
know I I can tell you right now if you
know the way I travel in the way
probably most you travel there's no
reason for me to see an individual until
I get on the airplane there's no reason
to have an interaction with there even
to see an American Airlines employee
because I'm not checking a bag and I've
got my boarding pass my iPhone and I
hand it to someone who then puts it
under the thing and I can do that
so but we're not allowed to not have an
agent stand there and just let an
individual decide that they're going in
the airplane so some of this is so this
is just requirements that we're always
going to have but we can do a lot better
and we're working really hard I can tell
you and air lines as it relates to this
we now have we're putting internet onto
our international flights it's not on
all of them yet
but we're way ahead of the way ahead of
the game there so transatlantic transits
things you couldn't do before it's now
work now well now we're shooting up
satellites instead of going down to cell
towers and with that technology that was
that's new technology now we can
actually provide Wi-Fi service anywhere
on the anywhere in the air so we're
moving to that as quickly as we can so
we'll keep working on it but do we agree
with you
I'm afraid I'm gonna take the last
question for myself which things which
is you earned it thank you I've tried
what advice do you have for the MBAs in
the room if you could go back and it's
your time at Owen what do you wish you
could tell yourself well anyway the
again so many of you go off and live in
your basement so I'm not sure what to
tell you about about how to do that
you're you're smarter than I am but the
what I tell you is what I do know at
least from a more traditional
perspective where you go show up at a
job is
I was I was honored the party
introduction to have this the
relationships matter piece mentioned
that's what I think what I believe is
and what I would what I would I would
encourage what the reason was I was
talking to a group like this and what I
told him is look you know I what I have
learned in my career that it's I know
it's taught in business schools and it
seems so
matter of fact that what even teach it
but you can't stress it enough is how
important relationships are and how you
treat people in your relative success
and you know this there's this there's
this perception of amongst some you know
outside of business that businesses is
this you know the way you get ahead is
you know backstabbing cutthroat that
doesn't doesn't work at all it
absolutely I mean they work for a short
period of time but show me you'll be
done and you'll go need to find another
job before too long in another industry
it doesn't work what matters is people
that in every relationship they have you
treat people with respect and dignity
and you you with you show up and do your
job well and what what I don't think
well I watch people I don't think they
fully appreciate is the time you walk in
the door that starts and you're building
relationships with people and you're not
you don't have any idea
you can't possibly decide
oh that's person somebody really did
have relationship in that person's not
that's what I've learned through all
this crazy story of all the stuff that
I've been through I mean this American
Airlines US Airways merger we ended up
with people in part of this process that
helped us out that you know said oh yeah
15 years ago you know you we worked on
this project and and you know at that
time there's no way we would have
thought that individual was going to be
representing you know the flight
attendants who were really important to
us at the time but thank goodness we
treated that person well 15 years ago
and if we hadn't and they hadn't been
treated maybe so well for them from the
other side it made a huge difference so
anyway the message is this you're going
to the day you walk in the door you're
going to start
relationships and people are and you and
if you try and say I care about that
person that that person that's not going
to work so treat here by the same treat
everybody and if you do that you will
just the people that do that versus
those who don't too dramatically better
and I think that's the biggest keys
anything so you have give some of the
same intellect energy integrity all that
but you know not the ability to to to
build relationships with somebody who
can and they're going to have
dramatically different careers so that
would be my advice just be nice to
people that's great advice thank you so
much